we are no um you know I I do think you
have the perez hilton's of the world and
you know people have very mixed feelings
about him but I do think he's one he's
sort of mastered the act of immediately
reporting information as it breaks the
accuracy is sometimes in question but
really reporting that information
without the corporate the corporate
conflicts that could come I do think you
also when you do have you know higher
profile writers or bloggers in this
business like him who are so ingrained
in the machine themselves at this point
are you going to see a really terrible
Paris Hilton item on his site probably
not Willie trash lindsay lohan and his
chance he gets yes because there's there
are those relationships in place but I
think that's really interesting that it
went from something really organic to
almost a cog in the machine by itself
one thing that we're really proud of I
mean on the media end is the firing of
Judith Regan and we broke that story
ahead of anybody thanks to a great
source and you know that that story
really reverberated through racial and
you know anti somatic channels through
the publishing and media industries all
the way to the the celebrity Avenue with
OJ Simpson so that was a pretty
significant story for us
you always do look back because the
story is never dead and if accurate info
if if we're shown to have been
inaccurate in the past or another party
pops up and has a side of the story to
tell we are more than willing to to
relay that information and I think
what's different about blogs is you know
one item is not the end-all it can be a
series of two or three or 20 or 80 items
that really create the story whereas if
you're you know talking about a
celebrity weekly they have one issue to
get it right theoretically then they go
back the next we can contradict
themselves but you know that that's sort
of the point but you know with with
blogs if we get something wrong we
update that item immediately certainly
we try to be wrong as little as possible